movies sometimes languish in development
hell for years before making it to the
big screen and many more indepth
cancelled somewhere along the way this
holds true even at Disney where the
costs of traditional or computer
animation can spell doom for a troubled
production here's a look at some of the
most intriguing projects Disney has
shelved over the years and the reasons
why audiences are unlikely to ever see
them gigantic following the Disney
tradition of drawing from classic
folktales gigantic was planned as a
retelling of the English fairy tale Jack
in the Beanstalk
this wouldn't have been the first time
that Disney had tackled the classic
story in 1947 the studio released the
war-era packaged film fun and fancy-free
that movie included two musical animated
shorts one of which was the popular
Mickey and the Beanstalk you remember
that one right where Donald Duck tries
to slaughter a cow they don't make them
like they used to a wowser anyway
gigantic was announced with fanfare at
the 2015 d23 expo and it seemed that the
project was already well underway
tangled director nathan Grinnell was on
board to lead the film's development
later joined by inside out screenwriter
mag LaFave husband-and-wife songwriting
team Robert Lopez and Kristen
anderson-lopez were to write the score
no doubt hoping they could recreate the
magic and commercial success they
captured with the oscar-winning frozen
soundtrack originally slated for a 2018
release Disney announced in April 2017
that they were pushing gigantic back to
2020 giving the wreck-it Ralph sequel
the 2018 slot instead apparently even
two extra years of development time
weren't enough just six months later
Walt Disney and Pixar Animation Studios
president Ed Catmull told variety that
Disney was ending active development on
gigantic instead focusing on a new and
unspecified project set for Thanksgiving
2020 king of the elves legendary science
fiction author philip k dick novel z'
and short stories have long been a
favorite of Hollywood Studios Blade
Runner a Scanner Darkly Total Recall and
Minority Report were all based
his written works Disney jumped on the
bandwagon in 2008 when they announced
that they were planning on creating an
animated feature based on the king of
the elves a fantasy short story written
by dick in 1953 king of the elves was
originally slated for a late 2012
release but it's unclear exactly how far
production got Disney Animation Studios
later removed the king of the elves page
from their website so it's pretty safe
to assume that the movie has been
shelved indefinitely
nute Disney revealed a number of their
upcoming projects in a 2008 press
release including the proposed Pixar
animated films the bear and the Bo and
Newt well the bear in the bow eventually
found its way to the big screen in 2012
as brave the production of newt was much
more troubled originally planned for a
2011 release newt was to tell the tale
of the last remaining male and female
blue-footed newts forced together by
hopeful scientists in order to save
their species only to discover that they
can't stand each other
if that plot sounds familiar that's
because it's essentially the storyline
found in the 2011 Fox animated feature
REO hey wait did you actually think we
were gonna kiss no no no I think they
need a little hope after finding out
that Fox had beaten them to the
box-office with the very similar tale
Disney Pixar canned their plans for Newt
in a 2011 interview John Lasseter then
the company's chief creative officer
acknowledged that the parallels between
the two films were behind newts
cancellation where the wild things are
speaking of John Lasseter in the 80s
when he was just an animator at Disney
he helped explore the new technology of
computer drawn animation at the time
Disney owned the rights to Maurice
Sendak's classic children's book where
the wild things are and had been
considering adapting it Lasseter began
working on a short CGI featurette
designed to be a test of the burgeoning
new computer technology at the time
though executives at Disney weren't
interested in using computer technology
unless it could make the production
process faster or cheaper Disney
eventually lost the rights to cindex
book and the whole project came to a
halt wildlife you may have heard of
George Bernard Shaw's play Pygmalion but
your
likely more familiar with some of the
popular adaptations of the tail-like
1964's my fair lady starring Audrey
Hepburn or the always classy take
presented in 1999's
she's all that heyno check up the bow
goes on super freak then again my fair
lady did have this scene in the early
2000s Disney's secret lab developed
their own version of Shahs tale an
animated feature film called wild life
the details of the proposed plot are
sketchy but the movie was to be a modern
interpretation in which an elephant
named Ella
becomes an instant celebrity in the new
york city club circuit legendary disney
artist hans Bakker worked on the
ill-fated project for two years and he
shared some of the concept and character
art for wildlife on his personal website
Disney eventually pulled the plug
because of story issues and the fact
that the dialogue was peppered with too
much adult's humor Yellow Submarine in
the late 2000s Disney floated plans to
develop a motion capture remake of
Yellow Submarine the acclaimed 1968
animated film based on the music of the
Beatles Robert Zemeckis was supposed to
develop the remake with the film
experienced numerous setbacks along the
way
Disney finally confirmed the project was
under way in September 2009 but despite
all the hype the Yellow Submarine would
never resurface although it hasn't been
confirmed it's been suggested that
Zemeckis is dedication to the imperfect
motion capture techniques used in his
previous films like a Christmas carol
the Polar Express and Beowulf probably
contributed to the sinking of Yellow
Submarine
when Zemeckis next motion capture
project Mars Needs Moms flopped
spectacularly at the box office in 2011
Disney cut both Zemeckis and his Yellow
Submarine project loose The Nightmare
Before Christmas too after the
unexpected success of The Nightmare
Before Christmas in 1993 Disney was
eager to capitalize on the film's
widespread acclaim originally released
under Disney's touchstone pictures
banner because of the movie's spooky
content Disney later fully embraced the
Nightmare Before Christmas releasing it
in theaters for several years
running and even spending a bundle to
digitize the film for a 3d release in
2006 but those reissues weren't the only
plans Disney had for the film according
to director Henry Selick Disney started
floating ideas for a possible Nightmare
Before Christmas sequel around 2001
celica claimed that the studio execs
wanted the sequel to be CG instead of
the stop-motion techniques used in the
original film it seemed that Tim Burton
himself who produced and conceived at
the tale shut Disney down on the sequel
talked in a 2006 interview with MTV he
explained I was always very protective
of Nightmare not to do sequels or things
of that kind it's not a mass-market kind
of thing it was important to kind of
keep that purity of it
Tamlyn after his blockbuster success
with The Lion King in 1994 and his
equally successful Broadway musical
version of the film director Roger
Allers turned his attention to a new
Disney production the kingdom of the Sun
was his pet project but after conflicts
with Disney over the story and direction
of the movie Ahlers ended up making the
decision to leave the production which
was retooled and released as the
Emperor's New Groove in 2000 Alice
turned his attention to lilo and Stitch
and began to develop a new story pitch
based on The Ballad of Tam Lin a
traditional Celtic folktale Ahlers
developed the pitch but ultimately the
internal politics at Disney Studios
during this era kept Tamlyn from ever
being developed Ahlers explained I did
it for Roy Disney who was eager for an
Irish tale but Michael Eisner the head
of the company was in conflict with Roya
on many matters at the time and when I
pitched it to him he rejected it because
of its Irishness Michael Eisner the CEO
of the Disney Company and Roy Disney a
leading member of the board of directors
and an animation champion who were
engaged in a struggle of whose vision
for the company would prevail with the
result that some pictures became
casualties of that struggle
although Tamlyn was later picked up by
Sony Pictures animation in 2003 Ahlers
said the team at Sony couldn't agree on
how to approach the movie and all plans
to develop the picture were scrapped the
Emperor and the nightingale Disney has
long turned to the fairy tales of Hans
Christian Andersen and others to inspire
their animated and live-action films one
of these tales the
Gale was first floated as a possible
Disney adaptation in the 1940s since
then numerous attempts to get the
nightingale to the big screen have all
fallen flat
although Disney did manage to put out a
children's book adaptation the Emperor
and the nightingale was reworked as a
computer animated project in the spring
of 2003 but less than six months later
the project was shelved yet again this
time indefinitely Who Framed Roger
Rabbit sequel director Robert Zemeckis
took his yellow submarine remakes defeat
in stride and turned his attention to
developing a sequel to Who Framed Roger
Rabbit for Disney Zemeckis seemed to
have both Disney and original Roger
Rabbit star Bob Hoskins on board for his
sequel but then Hoskins was forced to
retire from acting due to his ill health
and sadly passed away in 2014 which
seemed to spell the end for any talk of
a Roger Rabbit sequel never want to
admit defeat
Zemeckis claimed in 2016 that he had a
terrific script in place saying it would
be very hard to do but we would do it
digital Bob Hoskins before you get too
worried about what Robert Zemeckis plans
to do to Hoskins legacy rest assured
that it's extremely unlikely Disney will
ever make this picture and Zemeckis
knows it he admitted the current
corporate Disney culture has no interest
in Roger and they certainly don't like
Jessica at all I'm not bad I'm just
drawn that way sure you're not Jessica
you keep telling yourself that
[Music]